Just as an aside, I'd like to actually show you an interesting example of
what would be an ideal focal length for taking images or portraits.
Again, I have my scene.
I have my camera.
I can use an 85 millimeter lens and get the whole field of view that I want.
In this case, I'm using a simple example, a bust of Abraham Lincoln.
I'm using this 85 millimeter lens and this is what the shot I get.
I move closer.
This is a 50 millimeter lens now looking at the same subject.
Here's the output.
It does get darker a little bit for a variety of reasons.
We'll be looking at that in more detail when we
talk about the exposure triangle.
But you notice that
there is a little bit of a difference between these two images.
Right?
If I was to just basically say,
these lips here seem to be now much more smaller than this one.
But actually let's go in further and see if we can move further and
see what happens.
Moving the camera further in.
And since I want the same field of view, I would of course, and of course I
have the same sensors, the same camera, I would have to change the focal length.
This is what telephoto lenses are usually very good at.
And of course, now you see a 20 millimeter lens, and this is the image we get.
If you notice this face now has a little bit more distortion.
It feels more curved, and much more kind of all things,
the dimensions seem to be, and the dimensions have shrunk a little bit.
And the nose seems a little bit more kind of
projected outwards as opposed to in this case the face looks much more facelike.
So here there's a lot more distortion.
Now, of course, most photography is, you know, again,
what you want to do with it, but just by changing these types of things or
parameters on your camera, you can change the look and feel of an image.
So traditionally, most portrait lenses that
people use are 75 millimeters to 135.
I actually prefer to use an 85 millimeter.
This is one of my favorite lenses.
because it actually gives your portrait, and
of course there are other things that are going on that we'll also look at,
as, you know, issues around,.
Little bit of more blurring in the background, which is less kind of visible in
these ones, but are much nicer in this kind of an image.
So in the next lecture, when we look at the exposure triangle,
we'll be looking at the relationship, of again details that allow us
to kind of also get more information the back and the front of an image.